[Applause]
this was Liz truss's first prime
minister's question since her government
outlined its tax cutting mini Budget on
the 23rd of September that sent the
pound tumbling in the UK economy into a
tailspin on Wednesday the leader of the
opposition paid did a bleak picture the
Taurus went on a borrowing spree sending
mortgage rates through the roof they are
skyrocketing by 500 pounds a month and
for nearly 2 million homeowners their
fixed rate deals are coming to an end
next year they're worried sick and
everybody in this house knows it they
won't forgive they won't forget and nor
should they starmer asked trust if she'd
commit to promises she made when
challenging for the conservative party
leadership not to cut public spending
absolutely like absolutely
[Applause]
look Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker what we will make sure is
that over the medium term the debt is
falling but we will do that not by
cutting public spending but by making
sure we spend public money well the
prime minister's insistence that she
won't be cutting public expenditure has
been met here with a fair amount of head
scratching her colleagues have been
saying that there will have to be cuts
for now at least Liz trust seems to be
saying that the shortfall created by her
planned tax cuts will be met by higher
borrowing the bank of England stressing
Friday will Mark the end of its
intervention in the government bonds
Market as interest rates rise it spent
billions to protect Pension funds so
there's still a degree of nervousness in
the city and the conservative chair of
parliament's Treasury select committee
now says quasi-quarting the chancellor
of the exchequer will have to row back
on tax cuts when he announces his full
Financial plans at the end of the month
what the government does next will
impact millions of households and it's
room for maneuver is shrinking Nadine
barber Al Jazeera London